during his four years as Brazil's
president and after that James bolsonaro
followed in the footsteps of his
political Ally former U.S president
Donald Trump
Cried Out fraud before losing October's
election to left-wing candidate vizinasu
Lula da Silva osonaro is now at the
center of at least 16 different legal
inquiries and for the first time he's at
risk of being banned from participating
in the next two presidential elections
it's common for presidents in Brazil to
face legal inquiries after they leave
office but bolsonaro broke all records
he's the former president that will be
facing the greatest amount of Trials
so far the most serious one is the trial
at the Supreme electoral court bolsonaro
is being accused of having abused his
power as president after meeting with
foreign ambassadors three weeks before
the elections and telling them that
Brazil's voting system could be easily
rigged those claims were unfounded
Brazil's electronic ballots have been
used for more than 20 years and
repeatedly tested before each election
the Supreme electoral Court will now
decide whether bolsonaro used his office
to undermine public trust in the
Integrity of Brazil's election
if convicted he may become ineligible
for running for public office for the
next eight years his supporters say he
did nothing wrong
bolsonaro was very transparent with
ambassadors he really had doubts of the
security of the voting system and stated
them but he never attacked Brazil's
democracy
is also being investigated for allegedly
inciting his supporters to storm
Congress the Supreme Court and the
presidential Palace one week after Lula
took office
the riots mimic the uprising of the U.S
Capitol led by Trump's followers with
like bolsonarus believed the election
had been stolen even if bolsonarus
convicted he's still a popular
politician among Brazil's conservatives
the right and center right grew with
bolsonaro and are here to stay they have
a strong presence in Congress and they
elected the governor of Sao Paulo
Brazil's richest state also sonata's
party is still hoping that he will make
a difference in next year's Municipal
elections and that he will help elect
conservative Mayors across Brazil even
if he's barred from running for office
Monica not give Al Jazeera Rio de
Janeiro